you
look up into the night sky and most
times the second or on a moonless night
like tonight the brightest light is not
a star but the planet Venus Venus is
only about a hundred days away as the
spacecraft flies but it's a planet
shrouded in mystery
scientists believe it holds important
answers to some of humanity's biggest
questions now as NASA prepares to send
our latest mission to Mars many are
looking beyond that - what's next
possibly Venus and a chance to go back
to the future the Merida spacecraft now
on its way to Venus is the most
intricate instrument in the history of
space science just three months after
President Kennedy made that speech in
September 1962 NASA completed the first
successful flyby of Venus a crucial
moment in the Cold War space race with
the Soviet Union
ten years later Moscow responded when a
probe reached the surface of Venus the
first time any country successfully
landed on a different planets Venus was
hot in more ways than one after a 15
month long cruise the Magellan
spacecraft will go into orbit around
Venus on August 10th in 1990 America's
Magellan spacecraft beamed back the best
pictures yet showing a hellish landscape
where the average surface temperature is
just under 900 degrees but for the last
three decades almost nothing Venus is
like a lost world you know it has mists
it's shrouded in clouds and mystery but
there's a whole suite of instruments
that we would like to send there to
unveil what's beneath those clouds and
really discover those secrets here at
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory in
Southern California sous mer car is the
number-one advocate for a new mission to
Venus when you look at this do you dream
of seeing someone there I dream of
seeing spacecraft there for the last
generation with Venus on the back burner
the main focus here has been on Mars
with another attention-grabbing mission
this summer
Mike Watkins is the labs director we met
him in the center of the universe
so-called because inside the
room nasa communicates with more
spacecraft at greater distances than any
other location in the world we talked to
them all we command them and we get
their data down through this room
the lab Watkins now runs was formed in
the 1930s focusing on rocket and jet
technology these days the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory no longer does any jet
propulsion that shift happened after JPL
successfully launched the first u.s.
satellite in 1958 a response to Sputnik
I think when that happened we realized
hey building that satellite on top that
rocket is the cool part and so we kind
of gave up on rockets at that time and
and and really country in on building
spacecraft the spacecraft Watkins and
his team will soon be tracking is a
still unnamed Rover the main focus of
the Mars 2020 project we watched the
final days of its assembly before it's
packed up in giant crates and flown to
Florida for July's launch they're just
about to lift this thing up Ken Farley
is the mission project scientist at Mars
2020 his job is about as daunting as it
gets
somehow get samples that could show
signs of life from Mars back to earth
there are no samples that have ever come
back from Mars there are samples that
have come back from comets but this is a
whole different business and if you're
able to get that that's that's big
that's huge yep
however the huge challenges presented by
Mars could pale in comparison to the
issues presented by another trip to
Venus it's been referred to as the hell
of the solar system it can melt lead yes
and there's tons of sulfuric acid
rainstorms
yes why go venus has so many lessons for
understanding you know rocky planets in
general and particularly understanding
earth scientists at nasa say venus was
probably the first planet in our solar
system to have the conditions to allow
life to form but its atmosphere is now
at 97% carbon dioxide a heat-trapping
gas that's super heating the planet
finding out why that happened could help
us understand what
taking place here on earth we can learn
about the very early processes that
shape the surface of the earth if we
study what's going on today on Venus and
we have this greenhouse that it's
incredibly intense on Venus so it has
tons of lessons for us to take in as we
try to prevent our greenhouse from
getting worse if you look at Venus the
Earth and Mars you see three almost
identical planets kind of in similar
locations they probably started off
similarly and they went completely
different directions
Mars turned into a desert with very thin
atmosphere I mean is turned into an oven
with a very thick atmosphere and we
turned out Goldilocks just just perfect
and I think scientists would like to
understand exactly how did that happen
and what drove that three planets three
very different directions but all with
important lessons as the team working in
the center of the universe tries to
answer the central scientific question
is there life out there I have to
believe there is it's pretty crazy to
think about it is it's also crazy to
think it's it's more inert reach now
than it's ever been before there are
three big missions right now being
considered to Venus and we should know
more about which one may or may not
happen in the coming months
I love the lessons Venus could bring us
I mean the greenhouse gas effect
absolutely I don't even know what to say
ninety seven percent carbon dioxide
right now on Venus and how similar all
these three please that's one thing
you'll learn this so fast anyhow
celerity were to begin with Earth Mars
and Venus and how dramatically different
they turned out and that's even to the
point of it's it's crazy to think that
there may be other life out there it
might be even crazier to think that
there isn't that were the only well
exactly that there was life there and
then no more I love to others face